hey everyone home welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
podcast here on the show our main goal
is going through every single issue of
Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons and don't
forget John Higgins over the masterpiece
of those free trade which is Watchmen we
are now on issue 9 so please visit your
first time listening go back through the
archives listen all the way up to here
we've also gone through Doomsday Clock
and we've looked at The Killing Joke and
you know it's so much content on the
channel you can also get in touch with
us watching The Watchmen part at
gmail.com if you've got any
corresponding Johnny feedback on the
issues on the episodes that we've done
watching Watchmen part as well and
Twitter that we don't really use I think
it's got like 10 followers need to start
doing that more but it's there so if you
want to on a social support it's there
as well but of course it's not just me
it is the the lorry to my doctor
Manhattan and death has a go man
life Oh life OH life how you doing Tom
I'm good I'm well thank you
I'm well well great let's just jump
straight in you know we normally do a
bit of preamble well I guess what one
little bit of preamble Marvel fanboy
excited for infinity war right it's like
the time for some yeah just just the
reviews have just dropped yeah and it's
getting really good reviews I'm going to
say tomorrow night I've already got a
video ranking ranking my favorite Marvel
movies from best to worst right it's
ready I just need to record the infinity
war bit and just slide in and it's ready
to go okay
have you have you already done your
infinity war ending explain video yeah
basically yeah Thanos kills everyone and
a couple characters die thanks fun make
sure you like comment and subscribe
that's a video that's a preview of it so
we're going to issue 9 the Dauntless of
mere being and I love this issue I think
this is a common theme us going through
making these notes they really just come
alive you know with the Cretans but I
think this is a terrific piece of work
and we open with the nostalgia bowl
that's the cover there that in full
flight but what I love is Laurie
actually throwing the bottle is
something that happens you know near the
end of the issue but throughout the
issue it's twisting in the air which
just you know kind of underscores dr.
Mann
of mega perception of the world yeah and
the sort of a motif this entire issue of
liquid getting spilt everywhere there's
a couple of drunks in there there's a
bit of huff did you spill my drink kind
of thing yeah it's really it's really
nice and poetic and it as nostalgia is
filling Laura's head she's throwing the
bottle as well which is a picked up on
that one Tom don't worry about that one
and you know we get a little bit of
terra firma okay we get flashbacks to
various stuff in Laura's life throughout
this episode for this issue but you know
the only thing we really get is just
moving straight on from episode issue
issue 8 and what I like is the question
Laurie you know the whole issue in
itself is questioning who she is isn't
it and it works on so many levels what
it's asking yeah it's really in-depth as
well and it's you know I don't want to
really slug her off too much but
Laurie's a pretty shitty character up
until this point I grate em she's
probably the worst character out of her
with a lot she's definitely she's kind
of the one that if he found out there
was gonna be an issue about her you'd be
kinda like oh sure I had a absolutely
stellar dr. Manhattan issue you had a
amazing Rorschach one and then you get
in the lorry one and you know going into
this you might be like no I can't be
bothered but it is it's it's brilliant
yeah yeah and yeah we get the sort of a
lot of odd stuff in this issue a lot of
sort of experimental techniques with the
paneling and I love this sort of
letterbox these black lines closing as
dr. Manhattan teleports him and Laurie
to Mars yeah you've got the clock in the
background there as well and you've got
Dan's horrified face which I absolutely
love the Gibbons whenever he draws like
shocked people that they're always that
really funny Wow
yeah yeah yeah you're so right I think
on the next page as well when we get to
Mars when Laurie's gasping for air like
especially at the bottom of page three
when she's looking up at him a cheetah
bulge in our eyes are really wide and
yet it's it's it's so vivid and you know
I love this movement again that the
camerawork the sense of scale that you
get of Mars these issues fantastic
there's lots of paneling like at the
bottom of not a page to why we're sort
of moving up the hill closer and closer
to these guys
it's just expert composition yeah
definitely you you do realize it's not a
camera Tom don't you yeah yeah yeah I
thought I was worried that they were
gonna think what idiots hadn't thought
that already and yeah but Laurie chorgan
just kind of shows how to touch Johnny's
from reality and from the the fact that
he forgot that she needed debris yeah
like throughout this this podcast we
kind of spoken about how John is so out
of touch and I watched a brilliant video
by the imaginary access that explained
dr. Manhattan and basically this form
that he's chosen it's just a form and
it's not tangible when he separated from
his intrinsic field his consciousness
was all that was left and he's kind of
pieced this form together by moving
atoms around of him I think even says at
one point in the book that he doesn't
actually move he just manipulate his
surroundings to travel around him and
he's sort of the center of the universe
which you know was it seems a bit funny
on the surface that Laurie couldn't
breathe it actually kind of speaks
volumes to how above everything he is
and how he's kind of looking down like
dr. Manhattan like what point do you get
so powerful that nothing becomes
important to you I think you know a lot
of people look at dr. Manhattan like
he's got this you know he's reached the
zenith of power um but he's so powerful
that he's actually able to see
everything and that is sort of a curse
like people want to be dr. Manhattan to
be a super hero but he's never really
attached to anything and he sort of
moved beyond what's acceptable on a
human level um and he's unable to go
back that how things are because he's
he's able to be so powerful that he's
able to view time the way that he does
and he's able to travel without moving
it's just really weird like when you
start consider his sort of powers like I
don't want to say I don't want to kind
of compare myself but I did meet I did
music at university and I was so used to
analyzing it that it for a while that
actually became difficult to listen to
songs because my perception was always
like a sort of analytical thing like I
was listening to where like drums were
panned in if the guitar was like how
that was equalized and it really did
make it difficult to enjoy anything
because I was so powerful when it came
to music Tom and dr. manhattan's so
powerful he saw beyond did the art and
beauty of everything and he's just
seeing it on a I don't know analytical
level that's why when people I like
what's up doc it's like up is a to
intrinsic glory which is what I'm saying
yeah yeah and it makes a lot of things
look redundant a lot of things look
stupid in relation like even Laurie with
her belongings the sort of topple around
her they have no meaning I love her
looking up as well and him depleted from
color as you know the life is draining
away from her and there's lots of subtle
callbacks in Watchmen we don't need to
tell you this dear listeners you know it
happens all the time there's one that I
spotted in this issue that hasn't been
spotted by quite a few sort of annotated
watchman guides that I always
cross-reference my notes we've will get
to that a little later one of the wings
that one of us I did catches you know
her and the finger giving life okay you
can look at it's a Michelangelo for
example we on the Sistine Chapel would
be one but even remember when she's
tasting his finger I think in the first
issue in saying it tastes a bit like a
battery and you know which is it it's
not to be possible to think of these two
as lovers because there's no
relationship between them at all here as
we get through the issue and we we see
his sort of time grasp fortress thing
that basically he made the end of issue
for um symbolically death what what is
this to you that this palace um it's
interesting that it's made completely
out of glass because it's transparent
and even if it's there you can see
through it and beyond it and I think
this kind of some
dr. Manhattan himself like he's there
but he's not really there and you can
sort of see beyond him in the same way
that he can see beyond things and he
sort of trapped wandering through these
glass halls where he's able to see
everything but if you were to interact
with it it might just all break apart
it's very it's very symbolic yeah and a
lot of people have said that it's kind
of clock like as well you can almost see
the 12 coming from the middle there and
all the hands and you can almost imagine
it cubist seeing it all at once it being
a clock and I love the you know the
strict level that Gibbons has created
this fingers it has to be believable the
cats have to exist in it and move around
and the reflections as well a brilliant
aren't they when you see you know that
you plays a lot with them the way the
light bounces off the characters it's
it's a bit Sam obviously Andy reminder
it's very there's very Alan morphing
like I've been reading a lot of his
short stories recently his future shocks
and he often does a lot of sort of witty
sort of sort of jokes here and this is
all about predestination is what dr.
Manhattan is you know him defining
what's gonna happen before it happens
you know in her saying you know what
happens if I just stay down here and
screw predictions what happens then she
says as she follows him you know it's
really nice yeah and it's got my
favorite line from the entire book on it
and which is we are all just puppet it's
only but I can see the strings yes so
good yeah we're all puppets Laurie I'm
just a puppet who can see the strings
which explains everything
but it kind of makes me wonder if
there's a power above dr. Manhattan then
kind of controlling him
maybe you'll pop up in Doomsday Clock
the puppet master and it would be like a
giant Punch and Judy they finally got
like the higher power in Jeff Jones are
just drawn Alan Moore Oh Oh Alan Moore
is the god of the watchmaker that would
be amazing on an on a tangent there's a
Deadpool comic and called Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe and at the end of
the comic he actually breaks the fourth
wall and goes to like Marvel Studios and
the the writers are like discussing what
happened
on the panel as he walks in and starts
killing them that's how they should end
doomsday Club that would be amazing
yeah in the sixth book of The Dark Tower
song of Susanna Rowland meet Stephen
King and saves him from rain or accident
so you know it's yeah it's I think
Dickens did as well so a lot of people
play with that yeah Allen but I would
love that
they'll be the ultimate [ __ ] you Alan
Moore as well yeah instead of the big
vagina alien once service just a page
reveal of like Alan Moore I am big
vagina monster with long brown hair no
long brown beard I you know the
architecture not only of this palace but
Mars is charted for out this issue which
I love I love that he points to like the
Olympic mountain and the gaudy mouth he
says no discord Mountains which is Latin
for the Gordian knot which is obviously
awesome and dies his whole sort of
preoccupation what he's trying to do
here all of these exchanges I mean we've
discussed on so many for we both love
doctor went out and we both you know
fascinated by him as a character here
and you know him saying the time is
simultaneous an intrical intricately
structured duel that humans insist on
viewing one edge at a time and it's the
micro and the macro isn't it because a
lot of this is is Laurie looking back on
our own past maybe deep down she always
knew a comedian was her dad and just the
juxtaposition there we go of this story
with the you know astral planes that are
being explored now it's so well done it
kind of boggles my mind a little bit of
how brilliantly executed is yeah it's
great it goes from a one first-person
perspective of Laurie cleaning out a
glass pipe to then her as a child
cleaning a glass snow globe and again
it's something we kind of criticize
Doomsday Clock for the way Gibbons is
able to jump spans of like there's
across a panel and you can completely
get the context of it that it's a time
jump it's really really well done yeah I
mean it's it's something that you know
it's you wouldn't probably appreciate it
if you weren't a sad little man sitting
in your room
on a Wednesday night at seven o'clock
doing a podcast but yeah it's it's just
brilliant it's very hard to convey time
in that that manner and especially in a
form like a comic book but Gibbons just
you instantly know that you're now
looking through the eyes of Laurie as a
child without anything kind of pointing
it out
no no exactly yeah we just see our hands
the first person was like I love that we
see her mirrored as well and you see
from below looking up and seeing her
mother argue with Laurence the the sort
of PR guy who we learnt or bullied her
as well and was a bit cruel to her and
some people have said that the snowgo it
kind of has a smiley face aesthetic I
guess I can see it yes yeah I think it
does when you see a reflection yet again
it's maybe the smiley face yeah yeah
definitely and that the whole idea of
you know the lovely writing from Moore
as well the idea of slow time within the
blizzard and of course you were being
actuated by that and as we said before
death
it's the this the smashing that leads us
back and forth from flashback to the
present in this case here the snow globe
breaks and I love and this is something
that I just saw this afternoon when I
was making the final it's on the top of
page 8 we're in the snow globe you can
see Laurie's distorted face on the left
and Lawrence is kind of you know angry
dad on the right and both year carving
the castle it's terrific
that's brilliant I really do like this
section and it inputs you basically
Laurie sees her parents arguing arguing
over and she sort of unaware of the
context and it's sort of hinting that
her father isn't her father I don't
really know how I would have taken this
and if I hadn't already had the the
prior knowledge that the comedians are
dad and I love how this issue as a whole
just drops very very subtle clues that
you know at who a dad could be and it's
interesting the line that Silk Spectre
senior says of her futures taking care
of yeah and I don't know if that implies
that mothers sort of aware with the
relationship with dr. Mann
and or that she knows already that she's
gonna force her to be a hero which again
is something that's hinted throughout
and it's kind of humorous that she drove
her and the crimebusters meeting and
made her sit outside like it was a
screen test she saw a forcing her to
follow in her footsteps
oh yeah and which is very interesting
and it's very once again highlights the
mundane life of the retired superhero
like the the house that Laurie's walking
through it looks like [ __ ] and I've got
to actually applaud Gibbons again for
for being able to draw the mundane am I
was listened to I can't remember which
artist it was but I was listening to a
comic begin if you have comic book us in
a few ages ago and he was talking about
how he handed his portfolio in to DC and
one of the editors come out and was like
are you really good at drawing like
superheroes you really good at like
making all action seem intense and stuff
but you're absolutely terrible at
drawing like a telephone right or a
lampshade and Gibbons he's completely
mastered it like it
he's done such a good job of drawing a
very lifelike house yeah that you
wouldn't exactly think of yeah and it's
it's it's a form of predestination in of
itself like this fate there's dr.
Manhattan's fate where whatever is gonna
happen you're gonna end up doing this
but it also just your mom wanting you to
do something and cuz you're a kid she is
God like she used a horse in your hand
and you know it's just as valid there
and they you know they have some
wonderful arguments where more is really
plowing this you know the philosophy of
dr. Manhattan and how would this really
play out and you know he Manhattan sees
this dead Mars as important to him as
you know the blue world as he says and I
love this floating fortress that we see
is well there's lots of large panels
here the gravity of the situation as it
rises off the floor of course is is
classic you know it's Watchmen I'm on
page 10 I don't think I've ever seen
anything like this before in Watchmen
death the sort of the long panel on the
left that allows you to sort of get the
idea of the elevation they're going for
on Mars
yeah it really so but it's very well
thought of you see when it's it's
difficult for me to read Watchmen now
after seeing the film and kind of
imagining and making those leaps but you
know giving again does a brilliant job
with very little and you can totally get
the the sense of escalation just from
that picture alone I mean does Manhattan
is Jesus too many extents here in the
illusion so we see the water we see the
wine did you catch the whole the water
across our being like the smiley splash
no I didn't actually but yeah yeah sure
yeah yeah just just notice that but just
notice that this morning also the
chalice that she's passing becomes the
dumbell which is a nice kind of moving
move out here and it's just what dr.
Manhattan is saying is brutal but you
can completely understand it all that
pain and conflict on with all that
needless suffering over at last it
doesn't bother me all those generations
who struggle what purpose is they ever
achieve yeah so basically John's
discovered that Dan and Laurie are
sleeping together and he services link
with earth that he's completely detached
in his own fantasy world flying around
Mars and like his big giant glass castle
yeah um and yeah and I won't I went to
see ghost stories recently and check out
my ending I was going to that before
they take it down and that sort of has
the motif that reality is only what we
take it to be and with that gone there's
no real reason for John to say birth um
so it's just he's on a bit of a NEMA
he's a bit emo dr. Manhattan easily mood
and about you never see him just kicking
back with the guys just having a beer
and laughing which is my favorite thing
to do we get to see Laurie sort of you
know training here getting ready again
her fate as I say is kind of
predetermined and this kind of ties into
Doomsday Clock quite nicely doesn't it
with Byron Lewis we get to see I guess
in the timeline even though they're not
really supposed to mess up I guess this
would be like when he would have been in
the bughouse maybe hadn't probably
hadn't met red
yet of course he hadn't but you know
still was in that sort of world in that
sort of mode yeah I love them I never
used to like him I never even used to
know who he was Tom but that Jeff Jones
he did a cracking job with that guy and
he's probably one of my favorite
characters now in Watchmen communally
yeah he's great
no would take the piss out which ones
but you did he did do a good job with
that
oh yeah and it just sort of like a
flashback of lorry training and saying
all that effort what did it lead to like
it reminds me a lot of Batman nightfall
there's like a really funny bit in that
that's kind of stuck with me and whether
they talk about how working out lets you
live longer but you spend that time
working out right so it balances out but
you know I love a good work out anyway
Tom clearly yeah well you can tell look
I'm a Twitter profile picture that's
from two years ago Tom that my juniors
now look like dr. Manhattan someone with
a smaller dick I saw some would tweet
some Batman quote oh that's quite deep
in he was like why does a Batman key or
need be like because it'd be the same
Americal it's still in the world that's
a great great argument for it
and yeah we depends what what you're
watching Tom cuz I've seen Batman murder
a couple of people recently it just
drives around and he's caught shooting
people in there Batman V Superman he
pull he pulls a car have you seen Batman
V Superman well he basically driving
along he pulls a car full of people in
and throws it into another car killing
killing about eight people there but you
know it's just it's just a nice guy he's
not killing anyone now cuz if he did the
B or more killer in the world and
there's one more Spiller in the world in
terms of our friend Byron who drops his
glass drops his club soda which you know
initiates here moving back into the
present and it is I mean it's kind of
it's not it's never no hypothesis for
Laurie though because yes Byron's
clearly unstable but the other free
people alright I know our mom's bit of a
nightmare but I mean by all intents pubs
is Holly and Nelson are kind and
maybe Nelson's a bit fatter and Hollis
is a little older but you know times
have moved on here and we interesting
that what dr. Manhattan looking at Mars
here as well would it be improved by
pipeline putting a lot the sort of
humanistic elements onto you that you
can't really argue with and I can tell
you for a fact that Donald Trump read
that and thought I tell you whether it
would be a [ __ ] good-good need to
start drilling Mars I think that's the
next as the next thing here and you know
there's some there's so many good sort
of word games that more can do and on
page fourteen when they spoke speak
about chaotic terrain it reminded me a
little bit of an killing joke when Joker
shoots gored shots Barbara and does
loads of light dark book puns like about
like broken spine and coffee table and
all this sort of stuff and dr. Manhattan
getting his David Attenborough on and I
just say by the way what a glorious
panel this is at the top of 14 as the
glass palace is moving over it's like
the artist and Colour is to just you
know a masterful form here yeah
definitely Higgins he's knocked it out
of the park I make all my Higgins yeah
do you remember when I told them that
The Killing Joke the multiple colorings
of them were similar to the multiple
choice past of the Joker dish remember
that there yet really got really nice
and you know Gibbons
it's like watchman's got such a variety
in it like a lot of comic books they
kind of have the same locations over and
over and you get the feeling that
Gibbons has finally got time to like let
loose and just draw like beautiful
landscapes and just be really creative
with it instead of drawing a bookshelf
yeah and Hollis Mason's shitty little
flat for their 70 at the time so he's
probably having a great time with this
Tom yeah and as I say with the word game
so we get chaotic terrain you know my
mother eroded my adolescence cheaping me
into the shape she'd been if you hadn't
been me and I maybe
in the middle panel at the bottom of
page 14 you can sort of see a smiley
face if you turn it on the left with the
with the sort of eyes and the the
spillover of the liquid why why happy I
mean yeah just really what what I'm more
interested in I love the sort of warped
reflection of Laurie at the bottom of
page 14 in the side of the glass Palace
with the enemies with the Silk Spectre
earrings still employers think about
that are quite liked and here we get
back to the meeting the all-important
crimebusters meeting the I love it that
it's like it's just you see it from so
many angles and so much [ __ ] went down
here like here we get to see Rorschach
leaving and we had seen Archie fly away
in a past issue but here we get further
of a close-up for it but the most
important thing here is the comedian
meeting up with Laurie I love this scene
death yeah and it has them it has like a
clear hint again that the comedians
Laurie's dad your best mate they Mothman
you know he's not there but it's a shame
but the meeting you do see this from
every perspective and then this is kind
of the only moment where you get to see
beyond it and it's gets very dark very
quickly but she you know the comedian it
could be taking his flirting and but
obviously he knows it's his door yeah
and he says that she has all of her
mom's features um other than the hair
and if you look at the hair like they
have the same hair hmm so that's like
the biggest hint that they're related
and it is it's really good how more just
drops these hints throughout like
without massively confirming them it's
just very subtle and you could go
imagine that the first time you read
this if you didn't know you instantly
went back and reread it because there's
just so many little hints to it yeah and
beautiful when they passing a lawyer as
well and the mother coming out from the
darkness
clearly aged you know like yeah hung in
the crying bus or anything like that the
same way comedian has or any of the
other people have and comedians
vulnerable in this state really he's not
the sort of a great Eddy that we know
him as he's clearly quite
cow towels while the emotion is going
down here I think it's because he
probably did love Laurie at some point
pair not Laurie sorry so expect us young
yeah yeah at some point and he's just
kind of you know she's getting he's
trying to have a reunion with his
daughter and it's a you know we could
have had another daughter but you [ __ ]
shortish shot her in Vienna but yeah so
this is obviously his favorite daughter
and he's just trying to you know be nice
to her in Silk Spectre senior's furious
clay it's strange that she later
forgives the comedian and it's sort of
the psychology of victimization I read
our I read an article the other night
that discussed how people that don't
want to be labeled as victims do things
to prove that they aren't like forgive
this isn't my my opinions this is the
the article but they forgive and it
talks about their past that as if it's
like a good thing and in some Specter
senior definitely does this like when
she recounts about everything she kind
of looks back on it with rose tinted
glasses and I think she does have
consensual sex with the comedian at some
point to prove she isn't a victim like
in her eyes she's a hero but where there
she is or isn't isn't like it's not
really debatable I did this article kind
of discussed how and people who are
abused as children grow up to kind of go
on and abuse others because it's of them
proving that they're not a victim
because they're able to do it themselves
it's it's quite controversial obviously
and I don't really want to know say if
it's right or wrong
it makes yeah you can kind of tie that
into so expect a senior and how she kind
of talks about the comedian rape in her
and she was really angry and furious at
this point but when you see her when
she's older she sort of wants to shed
that that victim obviously because
that's when it becomes public as well so
everyone knows what happened and she's
kind of been over well actually it was
fine
I kind of wanted him to do it yeah to
kind of lose this victim thing and
retain the image that she's a hero yeah
and in the in the back matter actually
which is quite cool sort of the extracts
from a scrapbook the sort playboy faux
interview you know Sally says you know
the Chi bears some responsibility you
know just kind of me placed in the
sexual assault that chameleon does you
know it's not uncommon unfortunate for
rape victims you know a dozen of a human
layer to that character and it's quite
melodramatic both in verse of the the
shoes here it's like a sort of soapy
drama okay there is a guy saw a dress as
a comedian whatever but I love the the
coloring and also specifically her
walking up saying you take your hands
off her you can imagine that from a
Coronation Street or something like you
know it's very clear slag and like a
lorry looking back you know over as old
as the car drives away like I don't know
where the ready origin of that shot is
but that shot seems to be in every movie
like you know it's a very sort of common
thing here and the the splashing here
death is actually her mother's tears
yeah it's great again spilling liquid
and it's just motif as the the balls
tumbling and spilling more more and more
liquid as it's falling to the ground
it's really poetic more has killed it
Givens has killed it Higgins
our friend of the podcast killed it
I considered me in hip Higgins good
mates maybe best friends even well very
close I was really cringing when he
called me death that's when I realized
like nicknames are really stupid and I
was a I can't believe I've called myself
this but you know back to the book yeah
dr. Manhattan spoiler alert he gives
away the ending of the book yeah yeah he
talks about all the end you know killing
someone in the snow he talks about
returning the earth and the streets
being lined with corpses it's just
there's no spoiler alert anywhere on
that YouTube would have had a [ __ ]
field day again I love this position you
know were on the deck of the glass ship
going towards this mountain
you know man hand pointing out as well
which is a real thing apparently it's
the biggest mounting in the universe
olympus mons mountain how did they know
that they only know about nine planets
Tom one of them is not even a planet is
is it's a planet you know some people
say it's flat but yeah yeah that we know
about I bet this one I bet there's one
on the back that even everybody they
might be underground in this I don't
know why I'm getting so annoyed about
this so Bob wants there might be a
massive [ __ ] off planet on Saturn of
mountain monster and that we don't know
about and yeah I like I like this I like
that he predicts it but can't predict it
and he's sort of you know Moore's
offering a little bit of a weakness for
my man Hanuman dogs were build on the
tachyons or whatever they are but he's a
question that I mean sort will sort of
spoil the ending now when he marvels at
the fact that Laurie could happen you
know the magnitude happened didn't he
already know that that was a thing
before even happened so he already knew
he was gonna change his mind so didn't
have to ever change his mind or what
nobody has to go through the motions Tom
okay that's what you don't get the lad
has to go through the motions so he
knows everything but he still has to go
through the motions of it yeah you know
I mean yeah yeah I think that makes
sense I think we discussed this before
only dr. manhattan's a Buch bromide in
dr. Manhattan is the watchman book
you've got to have all this stuff in
chapter one to go into chapter two you
know I mean you couldn't just have
chapter four at the beginning Tom he's
gotta go through the motions one of my
favorite panels again is on Captain on
page 19 here just the huge sort of you
know fog Canyon yeah that there above I
think I like I like how he's been
talking about how the books gonna end
and Lori's kind of doesn't know what
it's like more like really angry about
it and really question it but John
doesn't really seem to care he seems
more bothered about continuing this to
her more
loads more to show you does the heart
does a human heart no Kazakh chasm so
abysmal and you know Laura again fires
back with this as well I'm talking about
sort of the world that she lives in and
we go to I think it's from Nepal I can't
remember it's the Ozymandias the Indian
I think maybe charity gala that comes up
a lot as well this is where we see for
example in another issue Hollis and dr.
Manhattan me and where Hollis is talking
about working on cars and dr. brand I
said I've synthesized a battery that we
won't need engines anymore or some [ __ ]
like that and yeah this this here here's
my spot he's my addition to Watchmen
critical appreciation so top of page 20
the tumbler that we're seeing Eddie in
with some sort of diplomat I don't know
about you but do you remember in the
second issue when Eddie rapes miss
Jupiter and it's kind of refracted in
Moloch solar when yeah if you compare
them if it's page six on issue two if
you compare them they're literally the
same it's it's Eddie reaching out in the
same way obviously it's kicking in this
one in here he's shaking your hand but
it's the same sort of idea and you know
I love that I love these little things
these little illusions here and this is
a different America than what we know
and I really like the fact that they
talk about Woodward and Bernstein
obviously all the President's Men
you know Dustin Hoffman and Robert
Redford the famous from the guys who
broke Watergate but in this America they
were found dead in a garage nice I
didn't know that yes obviously war gate
didn't happen working probably work
killed by the comedian yeah yeah exactly
because in the kinder field what what in
real life yeah probably well in the
garage is where they meet deep throat
who they release all the secrets to but
you know here that didn't really go down
I think I saw a video about someone
meeting someone in a garage
you know comedian is obviously a huge
[ __ ] war hero in this time here as
well he's got a scar as well which is
really nice which we didn't have before
and you know I really like Laurie here
and she's I like how she's got the dr.
Manhattan earrings on I just noticed
that as well
oh yeah the ones he gave to Janey Slater
yeah she she splashes comedian the right
eye which leaks onto his badge I mean
yeah ah like the blood yeah yeah it's
very good spot in creator you comb it
this yeah no mommy I think you're a bit
of a weak link Tom but you're killing it
this this quality it's a quality this
issue yeah I love like how um Edie's
comedians wears the badge even to these
Black Tie dinners it's like yep still
without the smiley on yes his brand
isn't it it is I was pretty good but
they didn't have this bit in the movie
and I because tuxedo events in films
cost a [ __ ] fortune Tom Kevin Smith
did a stand-up once and he was writing
the the Superman script in the first no
he got back was don't have this tuxedo
scene in it because it costs a [ __ ]
fortune a bit of movie I've completely
ruined the Pope I'm the weak link
no and well are you the weak link then
email us anymore
we got one email recently says he didn't
read up the whole thing out so maybe
that guy won't he would like shared
David though thank you female in in man
will will read out any future ones but
yeah um quite dark as well where he's
like she's like you raped her against
her will he was like only once which is
just yeah okay tell me it was only once
and you know this this world we learned
that this was the first time she got
transported off as well she confronts
him and you know he doesn't really have
anything to say back to her and we're
back on Mars back with his scrapbook
there's something quite wonderful about
tossing all these mementos into this you
know deep Martian Canyon I always loved
that I love the the way the Sun looks
against the glass palace as well in the
second to last panel just how crimson is
against those calico skies and then we
get to you know an interesting part here
where again this feels like something
out a cinema like you know when the
memories of a character
lessons all their life yeah I was in
that when I was reading it it's like all
the the pieces coming together and at
once stupid people like us you're like
huh
oh yeah um so yeah it's really well put
together and you're slowly starting to
get the reveal of who Lori's father is
yeah and it's just great that a lot of
the quotes are juxtaposed against
different images so like something that
said to her when she's 14 we see when
she's an adult etc etc and they start to
fill it up here and that shot of
comedian the shock of him looking
forward as well of his wingtips and like
you know he's our mouth [ __ ] love the
comedian what a great I mean to our soul
but he's easy he's a fantastic character
such a compelling character and Laurie
realizes what by this point I think most
of us have realized that she's the
comedian's door um I realize probably
ready a long time ago I can't really
remember myself to remember any reaction
to this did you see this coming when you
first read or knock or member yes yeah
didn't stick with me so nope um but yeah
three nice reveal but it's good that
they tease that out as long as well they
could have those several opportunities
throughout the book where they could
have done it but this feels like the
moment that would be most impactful um
just as you kind of desperate for John
to come back and save the world she
discovers this and she just breaks down
yeah in the glass Palace crumbles the
facade yeah yeah exactly yeah oh yeah
exactly the facade all comes crumbling
down and if you are killing it this
appreciate that man and she exists in
are in her you know inside the little
ball the Manhattan protective and my
hand you're sort of watching on like you
almost feel that he wouldn't even for I
need to protect her it would have just
sort of happened it would have just been
this you know omniscience there and it's
lovely how the skies revealed behind as
well and you know the stars kind of
Manning on now what your thoughts on
this final sequence where Manhattan is
drawn back to earth through the reveal
of the comedian Laurie that whole
relationship how improbable is there
is brilliant something that's really
stuck with me as well just the miracle
of everyone's life and how many
coincidences that to be for you to be
born
the odds are incredible that you're
alive
and this really hammers that home just
how every all life is a miracle and it's
all worth treasuring i life is still
completely unexplained and scientists
actually have no idea what causes life
and only life can create life so it's
very difficult to kind of pinpoint the
origin of it and it's a beautiful ending
to this this issue it's definitely one
of the most sentimental chapters and
Watchmen I really enjoy it yeah and it
you know it it pulls out to show the
University which is a miracle itself if
you think about all the planets and
everything how perfectly balanced
everything in the universe is I used to
be a massive atheist Tom but you know
you just look out into the galaxy and
you just I don't see how you can be but
you know it's brilliant it's really
we're getting deep it what do you my you
an atheist toy yeah I am an atheist yeah
I think it's just where my grand my
grandfather passed away I kinda looked
at everything differently
it's weird watch it later actually
watched him die and if you watch someone
pass away it's very strange but kind of
empty eyes think like I think there's
definitely intelligent design in the
universe at least because we'll take
Watchmen right so if you're an atheist
you think that everything happened by
random it all just kind of happened
there wasn't any design so if you look
at all the colors in Watchmen all the
pages and all the words and all the the
way the character that basically
everything of this watchman book if
someone said to you everything that's in
this book just fell from the sky and
landed in the book perfectly you would
say well no that's load of [ __ ] someone
clearly designed it so I kind of
transfer that to the world around me and
say
how perfect everything is and it yeah
we're getting very deep here Tom no no I
died yeah I know I definitely see what
you're saying yeah so is there a is
there a god death and maybe not but
there was probably I think there was
probably I don't think there's a garden
like the Christian sense that's
constantly watching everything I think
if there was a God it would probably
just be like dr. Manhattan where it's
just a consciousness that's able to do
what it wants but it's not aware of
everything and who maybe just started it
but it's just too much Tom there's too
much in the universe for me and not
believe that it's all come from
somewhere fair enough man fair enough
and this this crater that we see what
you mean we're getting Richard Dawkins
on the show next week
Richard Dawkins a John Higgins debating
that would be do you think more as an
atheist he's deathly he's an atheist
yeah he is because he's a wizard as well
no he's madly into his magic but I mean
worships a snake God that he knows isn't
real he just wants to get into that mine
state and ya know he's I mean a lot of
his early stuff he's very anti religious
as well but I don't know in terms of
like the order the universe yeah where
he stands on that level yeah yeah I'm
not like where I don't believe in like
like religions and stuff it's it's like
in it but just believe that you know
there's a meaning to everything and
everything's kind of bound together see
the thinking it's it's so well
constructed that how could you imagine
otherwise yeah yeah definitely see that
I don't know whether we've just evolved
against that grain and exist within that
sphere but you know we're um yeah we're
at the end of the issue and we'll find
out one day Tom we'll we'll fight when I
heard ed and people go go back and
listen to this podcast in memory and be
like yeah the world I'm glad they're
dead this was a [ __ ] terrible show do
did you know that the crater they show
is completely real yeah yes the crater
of girl Gau yeah yeah go yes I mean like
that yeah which is like look it's a
smiley face Tom it definitely definitely
is it's
not a reach it's got the two eyes he's
got the mouth it's a face yes so look
how perfectly Watchmen is put together
someone's clearly designed it it
couldn't have all just happened at
random now look at everything around you
how perfect it is it's not random Tom
God made the crater of gal so that it
could pop up in Watchmen and just as we
end sue mning out from the crater you
know issue one with Laurie and Dan
actually ends with them sort of rising
out from from the badge on the solar
industry and yeah I love the sequence as
well I was pulling out I'd say into the
galaxy and we end with um you know
anyone who's done a bit of a level
psychology loves a bit of Carl Jung he's
saying death is from memories dreams
reflections as far as we can discern the
sole purpose of human existence is to
Kindle a light of meaning in the
darkness of mere being yeah so similar
to how dr. Manhattan found meaning in
the darkness yeah yeah called young -
exactly it's not kind of a Jeff Jones
hackneyed sort of just this this has the
word quite I think Jones you know I've
been reading darkside war recently and I
really like by John so don't slag them
off well might have to get them on the
show one day if we hadn't won the show
I'll be nice because obviously he's a
legend yeah I would don't realize how
like getting John Higgins on earth or I
was gonna come on I thought I'd be
cracking all the jokes Tom thought I'd
be doing my my terrible Alan Moore
impression when you get people on you
you just think ah [ __ ] about not being
presence of a literal legend I know you
call it Watchmen like you know very few
high up right like anyone in the comic
book world would bow down to him you
know because it's just yet this is the
Beatles esque and we get some really
nice stuff if we get like newspaper
clippings em it just pisses me off that
a lot of the ham writing semi illegible
in a lot of these like I find it quite
difficult to read some of these things
yeah I think it's more for 1985 when
handwriting was very common yeah
and people just she's still reading it
but yeah I do I do quite like this
section yeah um it's it's the Sally
Jupiter scrapbook and it's sent from
Larry yeah
she's and it's talking about writing her
book that was originally called
she-devils in silk but it's now called
Sally Jupiter a lauren lingerie and it
talks about how sexy she was like I
think it even has her measurements in
yeah and it describes as a shapely 18
year old and this yeah it's very strange
like this is more bothered about a looks
than a crime-fighting
and which is sort of like so expect to
seen yourself but you never actually see
a fight crime yeah
and I look saw all that she ever talks
about yeah yeah I think she she mentions
to Dan in that earlier if you like this
is one of the roots we used to do an ie
and whatever but yeah you right you
never see them actually just busting
criminals we get a review for the film
as well which pans it horribly you know
it talks about the unconvincing and
dated footage of a stunt woman in
antique chorus girl costume engaging in
poorly staged fights with stock heavies
which you can totally imagine that's
what it would have started there and I
really like the only real act of sadism
in this film lies in releasing it the
only masochism in watching it yeah nice
which so describes Watchmen isn't it
yeah yeah and we get a little this
interview here specifically it's the
pictures of her is what the Playboy
interviews is to look like we've missed
a bit because I think it talks about she
gets a letter from Captain Nelson yeah
asking me up and I think there's a one
implying that hooded justice is gay yes
yeah yeah the reason and there's a nice
photo as well of mother and daughter
back in the day which is yes because
because Laurie before she realized that
the comedian was a father thought that
hooded justice was going out with her
mother and they kind of talked about in
this how that was a cover mm-hmm because
of the backlash that silhouette got for
being a lesbian yeah yeah the that gets
mentioned yeah you just skipped it you
were gonna just skip over taken
you never said you were killing it you
let yourself down there Tommy
and as it always is there isn't too much
in here I think what we spoke about
before is they kind of you know fleshies
out her a bit more in terms of the guilt
the Stockholm Syndrome she feels over
the Eddy stuff here and you know it's
all about the see me aside as you say
that's all they're really focusing on
which is kind of sad but you know kind
of true well it's sort of like the story
of feminism isn't it like how women were
deemed as objects even when they were
doing similar roles to men like the men
weren't getting this sort of sex symbol
status and you know she's very
overlooked of her importance and never
gets mentioned about a fighting crime
it's just all about a looks and it's
it's very interesting that she gets
painted out as a rape apologist as well
mm-hmm and she talks about how she
fought austere door and a crime fighting
it's just not about it's not a very
flattering interview and those photos at
the bottom on flattering either yeah
what's so great about normal life normal
life stinks you can ask anybody I'm a
mother I get worried about her and it's
just it's it's it's kind of odd and
twisted really it's kind of like you
know watching The Sopranos at the moment
it's the same mentality of being in the
family and getting your sons involved
and into something that you know is
really dangerous and has you know
horrific side effects but yeah that
closes out a fantastic issue you know
this won't be one of my favorite issues
of Watchmen yeah I just think it's
perfectly told skillfully balanced but
you know they've all been terrific and
we will bear back soon digging into
issue ten she's got three issues left
people but plenty oh we've covered so
much really but yeah two riders were
approaching is issue ten so if you have
any feedback any reviews for the show
what did you think about issue 9 and our
thoughts on that get in touch with us
watching The Watchmen pod at gmail.com
got the Twitter and description as well
please subscribe to deaf Channel where's
his house leave a comment below on the
video share it you know put it in any
groups that you enjoy definitely closing
foreskin
I've been reading The Walking Dead
recently right and that's really really
good I got the compendium and I tell you
what it's brilliant if you don't like
the TV show and check that out because
it's it's a very very good book yeah and
I also got Suicide Squad hell to pay and
which is an animated DC movie I've
actually I don't know what the hell's
yeah you know when you just go on a
splurge of just buying things oh yeah
and I bought about keep my voice down
because my fiancee okay no he'll if she
hears this
I bought about 20 DC animated movies the
other day Tom okay now don't tell anyone
that
but yes suicides got how that pays the
most recent one it's definitely one of
the better ones and it really catches
the frantic feeling of the team that was
missing like from the new 52 run it's
really gory and it I like how DC are
kind of bringing back a lot of their
old-school characters it's got punch
into the Annette I don't want to spoil
it but it's definitely worth checking
out I also got death of Wolverine which
was hated by a lot of people and I
thought I thought it was good like it
had a bit of an underwhelming end but
it's still enjoyable it's like the rule
role Wolverine and you know ties nicely
in with his origin darkside Walsh I
mentioned before I'll read it when it
first came out I didn't really like it
that much but I think it's great now it
kind of ties into like the new gods in
the fourth world stuff I'm so you kind
of have to be up on that to appreciate
it fully but it's brilliant
alright have you got anything you've
been reading nothing really to be honest
review I tried to get a sheriff of
Baghdad as a mentor I didn't really
enjoy it to be honest review I found it
a bit dense maybe only to read it but
yeah but death this has been great man
thank you again bro
yeah take care it's a good name from me
it's a good night friend quick
you